I've only been eating meat for beef
fundamentally for almost five years now
I never imagined in my wildest dreams
number one that you could just live on
meat and number two that it would have
such a salutary effect so for me a guy
lost 52 pounds in seven months
I went from 212 pounds to 165 which is
exactly what I weighed when I was 23 and
I've maintained that weight since I can
put on muscle mass with no problem even
though I'm 62. and so and I've talked to
many people who've lost like a hundred
pounds in a year you know because they
come to my talks and who are just beside
themselves so to speak as a consequence
of experimenting with this diet so well
so that's the story